economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela buena
noche bienvenida la tasa de desempleo en
eeuu volvió a un dígito así es ramón muy
buenas noches en agosto de este año se
agregaron 18 millones de nuevos empleos
entre públicos y privados eso permitió
que la tasa de desocupación continuará
desacelerándose durante este mes raúl se
desaceleró en agosto y llegó al 84 por
ciento aunque el departamento de trabajo
reconoció que la cifra está un poco
distorsionada por personas que fueron
clasificadas como empleadas pero
ausentes del trabajo en todo caso la
tendencia que se observa es de
recuperación como vemos en el gráfico
antes de la pandemia el país gozaba de
la tasa más baja de desocupación en
medio siglo y en abril fue su peor mes
desde la gran recesión
a principios de este año perdimos unos
20 millones de puestos de trabajo eso
fue durante marzo y abril y si miramos
ahora todavía tenemos que recuperar más
de 11 millones de puestos de trabajo
solo para volver a donde estábamos antes
así es daniela y eeuu pasamos a américa
latina porque colombia inauguró este
viernes el túnel más largo de américa
latina'
así se trata del túnel de la línea que
mide casi 9 kilómetros y atraviesa una
densa cordillera para ir del pacífico en
donde está uno de los principales
puertos del país hasta el centro de
colombia el proyecto fue concebido hace
más de un siglo pero solo inició su
construcción hace una década lo más
difícil fue superar las fallas
geológicas de un terreno bastante
inestable pero también la corrupción y
los sobrecostos que llevaron a
retrasarla varias veces
que esta cordillera que por muchas
décadas se sentía impenetrable para
poder unir a nuestro país fue vencida
por el ingenio fue vencida por la
creatividad pero sobre todo por el amor
patrio de cada uno de ustedes hoy este
es un día muy especial para nuestro país
pero es muy especial por ustedes
porque está la obra más importante que
se ha hecho de infraestructura en la
historia de nuestro país es un proyecto
de país raúl pero todo no es tan bonito
como lo pintan lo que olvidó decir el
mandatario colombiano es que este túnel
funciona solo en una dirección y que
falta poner en funcionamiento algunos
tramos de la doble calzada así dejan
hiela y colombia- pasamos a argentina
porque se logró otra reestructuración de
la deuda bueno fue un proceso más
sencillo que el anterior en el que
acordó nuevas condiciones para deuda
emitida bajo ley extranjera por un poco
más de 66 mil millones de dólares que
como recordamos fue bastante tortuoso
hoy anunció una nueva reestructuración
por 42 mil millones de dólares hay que
tener en cuenta que la deuda total de
argentina es mucho más grande de unos
323 mil millones de dólares lo que hasta
el momento ha hecho el gobierno de
alberto fernández es acordar nuevos
plazos e intereses primero lo hizo con
los títulos emitidos bajo ley extranjera
en este proceso del que hablamos y ahora
lo hace con títulos emitidos bajo la ley
local entre los dos suman
aproximadamente una tercera parte
a creencias ahora raúl lo que le falta a
argentina es convencer al fondo
monetario internacional para que también
le ayude a aligerar sus obligaciones así
es y entidades buscan unirse para crear
el banco más grande de españa son los
bancos españoles bankia y bankia de
madrid y caixabank de cataluña que
iniciaron negociaciones para fusionarse
y así desplazar al banco santander como
el más grande de españa lo interesante
es que el bankia está controlado por el
estado después de un rescate en 2002 así
que sería una empresa mixta con una
buena participación extra estatal el
anuncio disparó las acciones de ambos
bancos en la bolsa ya que no es un
acuerdo de poca monta estamos hablando
de activos de más de 650 mil millones de
euros y que juntos tendrían una tercera
parte del mercado para el indicadores
wall street del cerro en rojo en una
frenética jornada de altibajos en la que
el nasdaq volvió a perder después del
desplome del jueves los datos de empleo
que los inversionistas siguen muy de
cerca no fueron suficientes para alentar
a los mercados y en europa también
cerrar
a la baja por su parte en américa latina
de las principales plazas subieron
ligeramente hoy pero cerraron una semana
negativa para finalizar que nuestra como
si fuera el día son los 1.328 millones
de euros que conforman el paquete de
rescate que completó virgin atlantic la
aerolínea del millonario richard branson
a su vez esta prensa anunció que va a
recortar más de mil puestos de trabajo
danielle y con esa información entonces
damos fin a este bloque económico aquí
en france 24 ustedes gracias el
continuar con nosotros hay mucho más
para ver aquí en nuestro canal
[Música]